l'élection municipale deuxième tour à 17
heures un peu plus de 61 % de votants
c'est un tout petit peu mieux que
dimanche dernier mais beaucoup moins
bien qu'en 1983 le nombre des votants
avaient brisé les 68 % dès 20h tous les
résultats sur antenne 2 élection
présidentielle au salvador la guérilla
but d'empêcher le scrutin tu me sers de
guerre civile combats dans les rues de
la capitale et déjà des victimes
un nouvel art de dormir en france des
hôtels sans étoile anonyme parti apte
mais moderne à des prix défiant toute
concurrence enquête dans ce journal
voilà monsieur bonsoir les dimanches se
suivent et se ressemblent parfois dans
un peu plus d'une demi heure maintenant
vous connaîtrez comme dimanche dernier
les résultats mais cette fois ci du
deuxième tour des élections municipales
en france tout de suite le point sur la
participation à ce scrutin dans la
mesure où dimanche dernier le taux
d'abstention était aux alentours de 30%
il avait été le plus important dans une
élection municipale depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale depuis 1945
aujourd'hui on a un tout petit peu plus
voter que dimanche dernier
mais j'en est loin des chiffres de 83
dernières élections municipales en date
voyons tout de suite exactement ce qu'il
en est ce soir avec pascal guimier au
ministère de l'intérieur pascal et will
daniels vous le disiez c'est mieux enfin
un peu un tout petit peu mieux taux de
participation à 17h 61,1 % on a donc
gagné un peu plus d'un point et demi en
une semaine par rapport au premier tour
de dimanche dernier
c'est mieux mais c'est toujours peut en
effet à la même heure en 1983
la participation était supérieure de 7 %
par rapport à celles d'aujourd'hui
alors évidemment on l'a dit et répété
c'est le 9e dimanche électoral en moins
d'un an
les résultats auraient pu être pires il
faut bien le reconnaître ces municipales
89 n'ont guère enthousiasmé l'électorat
on peut d'ores et déjà établir un mini
palmarès du cylisme en tête juste avant
la haute corse le cantal avec plus de 78
% de votants en queue de peloton paris
c'est devenu une habitude avec un peu
plus de 40% de votants 2% de moins qu'il
ya une semaine ce qui est un comble le
second tour en tout cas n'a pas connu le
sursaut que beaucoup espéraient à droite
comme à gauche entre deux tours n'a pas
suffi pour mobiliser davantage
l'électorat
il est vrai qu'avec la multiplication
des tris
l'ère des cadres angulaire le second
tour semble parfois un premier tour je
m'explique il y à 74 villes de plus de
30 mille habitants où l'on trouve en
piste pour le second tour
trois voire quatre candidats
l'affrontement quand notre camp
l'affrontement manichéen droite contre
gauche perd un peu de son acuité en tout
cas de son évidence ce qui a pu troubler
une partie de l'électorat
merci pascal plusieurs points chauds
pour ce deuxième tour des municipales
des villes très disputée comme marseille
tout d'abord avec la présence vous savez
de messieurs vigouroux gaudin peser
roland sicard marseille oui daniel et
bien écoutez ce que l'on peut dire ici à
marseille c'est que le suspense est un
petit peu retombée depuis les 42 %
obtenus par robert vigouroux dimanche
dernier la participation n'est
d'ailleurs en hausse que de 0,7 pour
cent d'un dimanche à l'autre à 17 heures
c'est très peu en fait la seule
véritable incertitude c'est de savoir si
le maire sortant réussira le grand
chelem dimanche dernier il était arrivé
en tête dans sept des huit secteurs de
l'aide mais il y aura tout de même deux
points chauds le premier c'est dans le
secteur de jean claude gaudin là le
candidat positif n'avait pas franchi la
barre des 10 % dimanche dernier le
candidat des listes vigouroux devrait
donc faire ce soir le plein des voix de
gauche
une situation très inconfortable pour
jean claude gaudin menacé dans son
propre fief
et puis second point chaud le 8e secteur
là dans ce bastion du parti communiste
guillermis avait été malmené dimanche
dernier mais aussi risque ce soir d'être
emporté par la vague vigouroux donc en
résumé un grand favori pour cette
élection municipale de marseille c'est
robert vigouroux
mais vous le savez sur le vieux port à
marseille tout est toujours possible
à l'autre bout de la france strasbourg
maintenant avec la mairie qui pourrait
passer de droite à gauche cela dépend
notamment du vote des écologistes qui
ont fait un très bon score au premier
tour dimanche dernier olivier werner
cadre angulaire les alsaciens ont appris
à prononcer ce mot barbare depuis une
semaine
l'éruption du front national en alsace
et la percée des verts ont créé ici un
cas de figure tout à fait nouveau pour
un deuxième tour d'une élection
municipale
les quatre candidats jouent une partie
extrêmement serrée
le duel au sommet oppose vous savez le
maire sortant marcel rudloff eu des rcd
est créditée de 31% des voix au premier
tour à catherine trautmann
ps qui totalisait dimanche dernier plus
de 30% des voix les verts d'andré
buchmann et le front national conduit
par robert spieler sont les juges
arbitres de cette municipale si les uns
et les autres se maintiennent au dessus
de la barre des 12 % et bien le nouveau
maire de strasbourg ne devancera son
adversaire que de quelques dizaines de
voix seulement la forte abstention plus
de 40 2 % dimanche dernier est également
l'une des inconnues de ce deuxième tour
à strasbourg
si la ville bascule à gauche ce soir les
strasbourgeois connaîtront sans doute
quelques bouleversements de l'est au
nord maintenant choisissant une dernière
ville dunkerque où le ministre des
transports et de l'équipement monsieur
delebarre s'attaque à une forteresse de
la droite dominique laurier inquiète
indiscutablement ici à dunkerque les
électeurs mérite la palme du civisme en
taux de participation de près de 78%
aujourd'hui soit trois et demi pour cent
de plus qu'au premier tour trois et demi
pour cent de plus vous en doutez qui
peuvent peser très lourd dans ce scrutin
en fait il y à deux inconnues dans ce
débat somme toute assez classique gauche
contre droite michel delebarre ministre
les transports qui a présenté dès le
premier tour une liste d'union et peu le
gist compris compte aujourd'hui 4 197
voix de retard sur le maire sortant
claude aux voyeurs apparentés rpr alors
une question se pose
le candidat ps dans une situation
difficile at-il fait le plein ou at il
encore quelques réserves
deuxièmement et c'est peut-être le plus
important combien de voix du front
national
malgré les consignes officielles
d'abstention se sont reportés sur le
maire sortant
réponse dans moins d'une heure nous
arrêtons là ce tour de france nous le
reprendrons tout à l'heure à 20 heures
précises avec au début de notre soirée
spéciale élections très rapidement le
maximum de résultats gilles leclerc vous
êtes en plateau oui tout à fait daniel
comme dimanche dernier pour ce second
tour priorité avant tout aux résultats
plus de résultats et plus rapidement
encore ce sera bien là
vi ce soir dès 20h en effet plus d'une
dizaine d'estimation dans des villes
clés grâce à bulles bba j'en cite juste
quelques unes dunkerque strasbourg
cannes béziers quimper par exemple sans
oublier bien entendu deux secteurs de
paris le xiiie arrondissement et le 20e
pour les autres résultats aussi vite que
possible ce sera la tâche de patricia
charnelet et rachid arhab
pour le reste une présence de toute la
rédaction d'antenne 2 et d' europe 1
dans près de 30 points dans toute la
france
et puis bien sûr deux débats politiques
importants à 20h et 21h30
des analyses avec alain duhamel albert
du roy jean louis le scène et moi même
animation claude sérillon tout cela sous
l'oeil des caméras de jean-luc léridon
dans un superbe décor signé michel milk
en rendez vous donc tout à l'heure 19h50
voilà donc pour cette soirée comme sur
le continent on a voté aujourd'hui
encore ce malgré la grève générale qui
en perd chez certains électeurs de faire
le voyage jusque là bas mais sur l'île
aujourd'hui les esprits étaient disons
ailleurs on pensait surtout à demain
c'est en effet lundi matin que le
premier ministre monsieur michel rocard
doit recevoir les élus corses pour
tenter de trouver une solution à la
grève des fonctionnaires qui je vous le
rappelle réclament une prime de vie
chère encore sur place
nos envoyés spéciaux françoise joly
dominique merde à pied cinq ans barre
aujourd'hui les 200 habitants sont tous
venus à la mairie du moins ceux en âge
de voter ici la semaine dernière une
seule voix séparaient les deux listes en
présence
dans ce village pas de polémique sur les
charters électoraux les procurations on
laisse ça aux grandes villes de corse en
revanche présent maintenant dans tous
les esprits cette situation de crise
dans l'île
ça fait boule de neige jeudi rire
beaucoup de gens qui au début était pas
que j'irais se sentent concernés
pourquoi se sont ils concernés
maintenant
c'était à l'état la table et ça dure
depuis longtemps des vins satisfaction
et mécontentements se sentent délaissés
si monsieur vous vous êtes retraité est
ce que ça vous pose des problèmes
particuliers cette grève je me pose est
pourquoi en particulier parce que les
patients n'ont pas été payés pensions
impayées courbit qui n'arrive plus
poor's et aéroports bloqués lille est
plus que jamais ce soir coupé de toute
liaison avec le continent
un isolement qui pèse à tous ceux qui
sont en transit ici aux transporteurs
routiers aux passagers retenus dans les
aéroports un isolement que les corses
espère voir rompu demain avec la
rencontre entre michel rocard et les
élus de ligne mais une entrevue plein de
points d'interrogation avec d'un côté la
fermeté du gouvernement
de l'autre des élus qui connaissent la
détermination des grévistes des
grévistes partagés entre ceux qui
veulent à tout prix la prime
d'insularité et ceux qui préféreraient
des mesures pour contrôler le coût de la
vie à l'étranger c'est malheureusement
comme on le redoutait dans une
atmosphère de violence et même de combat
que se tient aujourd'hui l'élection
présidentielle au salvador deux
journalistes ont été tués ce matin dans
les rues de la capitale san salvador
l'enjeu est vital pour ce petit pays
d'amérique centrale le président en
titre le chrétien-démocrate napoléon
duarte gravement malade ne se représente
pas c'est le candidat d'extrême droite
qui est favori et la rébellion armée
d'extrême gauche boycott ce scrutin et
veut même l'empêcher
michel mompontet du salvador aujourd'hui
nous attendions pourtant des images d'un
vote démocratique des images de ce pays
accédant enfin pour la première fois de
son histoire à une élection libre
mais c'est une fois de plus la violence
et la guerre
comme une fatalité dans ce pays durant
toute la journée les affrontements entre
la guérilla et l'armée n'ont pas cessé
le nombre des morts n'est pas pour le
moment chiffrables il est certainement
considérable le front farabundo martí
aura donc tout tenté pour empêcher la
tenue de ces élections les élections
qu'il qualifié de farce
devant tant de violence bon nombre de
salvadoriens attendre encore avant de
connaître un jour des mesures
démocratiques dans les campagnes et
l'abstention de joe de force semble déjà
énorme dans san salvador la capitale
surprotégé par les forces de sécurité en
attente et de s'intéresser au vote entre
l'aréna d'extrême droite favorite est le
successeur démocrate chrétien de
napoléon duarte napoléon duarte
gravement malade et finissant son mandat
par ce vote
ce vote qu'il espérait bien démocratique
et pacifique
d'autres élections maintenant ils auront
lieu dimanche prochain on en urss
élections des députés au soviet suprême
le parlement pour la première fois
depuis 70 ans monsieur gorbatchev a
voulu que ces élections soient plus
libre que d'habitude des candidats non
officiels peuvent donc se présenter
c'est le cas d'un homme considéré comme
partisan du multipartisme en union
soviétique monsieur boris elstine dont
monsieur gorbatchev avait d'ailleurs été
obligé de se séparer et qui mène sa
campagne
je dirais presque à l'américaine tenant
des meetings dans la rue et entraînant
des manifestations de soutien jusqu'au
centre de la capitale moscou
thierry calmette
un dimanche pas comme les autres vers la
place rouge plusieurs milliers de
manifestants au centre de moscou qui
voulaient occuper la fameuse place pour
se rendre devant le kremlin
les policiers barraient les accès un
kilomètre avant aucun incident à
déplorer une manifestation presque à
l'occidentale une nouveauté
autre nouveauté un slogan clamé par la
foule le nom de boris
elle s'y sent qu'un chef du pc de la
ville il personnalise des aspirations à
la démocratie
écarté de son poste officiel pour
déviation bruxelles signer le candidat
aux élections du 26 mars prochain
elle signe un fervent défenseur du
multipartisme il se bat contre les
apparatchiks pour une vraie pérestroïka
en fait il veut aller plus loin que
gorbatchev dans les réformes
démocratiques ce qui gêne bien sûr les
caciques du parti
hier réunions électorales dans un
quartier de la banlieue moscovite
une dizaine de milliers de personnes
l'ont soutenu et avait fait la loi
électorale permet au parent pour partie
de nommer directement un candidat pour
certains sièges à pourvoir
rien n'était et helsinn serait ainsi
exclu la compétition électorale
c'est ce qui a provoqué les
rassemblements de ces deux derniers
jours
faits divers en france maintenant la
nuit dernière à san mamés en scène emma
une voiture tombe dans une rivière bilan
5 morts des jeunes de 14 à 17 ans ils
étaient dix à l'intérieur de la voiture
qui n'était pourtant qu'une petite fiat
ritmo une quatre places donc jeunes gens
s'était véritablement entassés dans le
véhicule pour rejoindre leur lieu
d'habitation séparés de seulement 4
kilomètres du bal où il se trouvait
auparavant
les raisons de l'accident sont encore
inconnues pour l'instant mais le
conducteur qui est rescapé de cet
accident a subi un alcootest positif
risque de pollution dans la manche au
large de cherbourg lundi dernier un
cargo libérien qui a fait naufrage a
perdu un conteneur rempli de produits
toxiques 5 tonnes de pesticides
dangereux
la marine nationale qui a entrepris de
récupérer le conteneur a dû renoncer
provisoirement en attendant que la
tempête soit calmée au crespo l'équipage
du cargo libérien coulé lundi dernier
les onze hommes se remettent de leurs
émotions en angleterre plus inquiétant
la cargaison 5 tonnes de linda hains
pesticides dangereux
la marine française a mobilisé sept
bateaux et trois avions pour les
retrouver
daudet de l'insecticide a été perdu
puisqu'ils sont extrêmement lourdes
rempli d'eau et l'état de la mer ne
permet pas la permission pour qui
prétend depuis hier nous avons entrepris
des recherches par chasseur de mines
pour retrouver le container vont couler
en ce qui concerne les dangers éventuels
de pollution vous êtes inquiet ou pas
vous en faites durer donc figé rien à
côté
si la météo le permet les recherches
devraient reprendre demain matin des
experts réunis actuellement à bâle en
suisse prépare une convention mondiale
sur les transferts de déchets toxiques
d'un pays à l'autre en attendant et bien
les exemples se multiplient de déchets
baladeur entre guillemets à preuve cette
histoire italienne de wagons de déchets
toxiques venue de la riche italie du
nord pour être débarqué dans le sud
beaucoup plus haut
mais cette fois ci la sphère a été
découverte à temps sur place notre
correspondant en italie marcel trillât
un train fantôme 28 wagons portant
destinée comme les autres au voyage et
qui n'ont pas bougé d'un centimètre
depuis deux ans plus exactement depuis
le 27 avril 1987 jour de leur arrivée
dans la petite gare tranquille de rock
et à san antonio dans les pouilles au
sud de l'italie
à peine le temps ce jour-là pour le
destinataire de décharger un premier
wagon avant l'arrivée d'un ordre de
réquisition du juge d'instance de la
juridiction la plus proche
les 28 wagons sont bourrés de scories
d'extraction de magnésium 1400 tonnes en
tout une expertise confirmera plus tard
qu'il s'agit de déchets toxiques pouvant
provoquer de graves pollutions de l'air
de l'eau et du sol
depuis plus rien ici on ne nous a
absolument rien dit alors les wagons
restent sur place en attendant de bonnes
nouvelles sur chaque wagon la signature
du coupable expéditeurs la société
italienne pour le magnésium dont le
siège est à bolzano dans le nord de
l'italie
destinataire la sogepie dont le siège
est aussi a volcano et dont le pdg et
comme par hasard en employé de la
société italienne pour le magnésium
on n'est jamais mieux servi que par soi
même en somme une société minière du
nord industriels cherchant à éviter les
frais de traitement de ces déchets
toxiques et qui croit trouver à
l'extrême sud une poubelle discrète et
bon marché
destinataire de ce cadeau empoisonné la
petite commune rurale de monter vers des
à qui on avait promis monts et
merveilles
l'implantation d'une fabrique d'hélices
d'avion employant 50 ouvriers sur le
site prévu
les fûts plein de déchets le contenu de
l'unique wagon décharger version
officielle des scories devait servir de
fondation au bâtiment
l'hypothétique venue à temps par une
mauvaise langue
le conseil municipal a déclenché
aussitôt la procédure qui a tout bloqué
dans la prensa
ces gens-là croyait pouvoir profiter
dans dix ans
de notre ignorance et bien ils se sont
trompés parce qu'ils sont tombés sur des
gens intelligents et capables et des
élus énergique qui se sont immédiatement
opposé à leur projet les deux
responsables du délit viennent d'être
condamnés à bolzano à quatre mois de
prison
le jugement précise aussi que les 1400
tonnes de déchets toxiques qui sommeille
sur l'envoi de garage doivent être
détruits par l'autorité administrative
compétente mais ils ne précisent pas
laquelle
alors le chef de gare de rock état s'est
fait une raison il risque fort de
prendre sa retraite avant le départ des
28 wagons qui prennent depuis deux ans
sa petite gare pour un dépôt d'ordures
rubrique société autrement dit occupons
nous maintenant de notre manière de
vivre en commençant pas un nouveau style
d'hôtellerie des hôtels sans étoiles
mais pratique et moderne tout de même à
des prix défiant véritablement toute
concurrence reportage de jacques violet
et jean-françois cheveux il y a toujours
quatre murs deux lits imposé par terre
et l'autre suspendu un petit lavabo dans
un coin mais plus des toiles 9 mètres
carrés seulement c'est la chambre
presque une cellule de la nouvelle
génération d'hôtels sorti tout droit de
l'imagination des spécialistes du
marketing hôtelier qui ont ciblé la
clientèle cette clientèle est constituée
du monde du travail avec des
représentants de commerce des
commerciaux des techniciens du bâtiment
et l'industrie et une clientèle de
jeunes nous avons eu énormément de
jeunes qui viennent chez nous tout
simplement parce que dans nos chambres
conçues pour recevoir trois personnes le
prix de 110 francs ramené à la personne
est inférieur au prix qui le paient dans
une auberge de jeunesse rentabilité
oblige s'il y a toujours un gérant qui
habite sur place plus de réception vous
dialoguez avec une machine comme un mini
thème après avoir introduit votre carte
bleue
la machine vous donnera un code d'accès
qui vous permettra de rentrer dans
l'hôtel et dans votre chambre
les sanitaires et les toilettes
entièrement en plastique sont au bout du
couloir les douches communes une pour
quatre chambres autorise génique
elles sont désinfectés après chaque
utilisation cette chaîne d'hôtels qui a
été lancée par le groupe accor envisage
500 établissements de ce type en france
et déjà des concurrents se lancent sur
le marché lui looten ici même système
complètement automatisée mais peut-être
un peu plus humain une gravure au mur et
surtout les toilettes qui ont été
maintenus dans les chambres
mais quinze francs de plus que la
clientèle qui vient c'est ce qu'elle
doit trouver pour 125 francs et dans
l'ensemble on est plus que satisfaite la
meilleure preuve est qu elle revient et
qu'elle revient souvent
on parle aussi pour l'avenir de chambre
parking sans fenêtre à la japonaise
des formules économiques fonctionnel
bien sûr mais on se prend à rêver aux
petits hôtels de province avec la
patronne le veilleur de nuit les parcs
et qui craque et les lit qui grince
oui c'était le bon temps est les loisirs
et le plein air occupe donc une part de
plus en plus importante dans notre ville
est donc normal que le salon qui leur
est consacré ce soit installé sous
l'immense parc des expositions du
bourget peta cette année on peut y voir
toutes les nouveautés en matière de
camping caravaning mais aussi tester les
produits présentés y compris ses
voitures qui font rêver beaucoup d'entre
nous reportage de valérie fournioux et
bernie mairie
depuis hier les faux du cat cat se lance
dans les bourbiers offrait des
constructeurs une curieuse façon
d'exposer son produit mais certainement
la plus efficace pour convaincre
d'acheter ces monstres de l' aventure
entre 60 et 300 mille francs
en fait c'est donc fait du kayak en
amateur pour s'amuser et passer les 8e
passe un bon moment comme ça et puis en
même temps va visiter le salon
le 4 4 un marché en pleine expansion
quarante mille voitures vendues chaque
année de plus en plus belles luxueuse
laventure oui mais avec classe et
confort pour le camping et le caravaning
la tendance et vers le haut de gamme et
même le quatre étoiles
la caravane est devenue une résidence
secondaire pour près de 8 millions de
français
on a voulu exprimer par le biais de ce
salon qu'il était possible de regrouper
au sein d'une exposition tous les
loisirs de plein air dans leur
intégralité
la nouveauté de ce troisième salon des
loisirs de plein air les animations sur
place
un avant goût des vacances et pour
certains la possibilité de découvrir une
activité jusqu alors inconnu première
pour un j'essaye et c'est pas facile
aussi de maîtriser un petit peu c'est
pas évident mais sont maintenant en vue
d'essayer d'autres ont préféré regarder
ce numéro de dressage une tendre façon
d'aller à la rencontre de la nature
sport après les rugbymen vainqueur du
tournoi des cinq nations le cycliste
laurent fignon vainqueur de milan san
remo le week-end se termine bien pour
les français avec un titre de championne
du monde de cross country pour annette
sergent cet après-midi en norvège
patrick montel en norvège annette a
refait le coup de varsovie deuxième
titre de championne du monde en trois
ans pour la lyonnaise un deuxième titre
amplement mérité sur le terrain de golf
détrempée de stavanger annette qui fait
la course en tête et s'impose facilement
22 minutes et 27 secondes pour les 6 km
anne est la locomotive puisque la france
se classe 2e par équipe
juste derrière l'union soviétique pas de
surprise non plus chez les hommes ou les
longues jambes du kenyan john gobbi ont
facilement émerger et ce pour la
quatrième année consécutive le champion
olympique du 5000 mètres n'a plus depuis
plusieurs années d'adversaire à sa
mesure il l'a prouvé cet après midi
encore en reléguant le britannique tim
hunt shins à près de 30 secondes
le premier français bruno le stim
termine 11e et nous terminons sur une
magnifique image de patinage artistique
comme nous avons vu beaucoup ce week-end
gala de clôture du championnat du monde
cet après midi à bercy à paris voici la
prestation du couple français médaille
de bronze paul et isabelle duchesnay
regarde
sans patins à glace mais avec des sabots
cet après-midi le tiercé vous allez voir
les résultats s'inscrire sur votre écran
pour gagner il fallait jouer le 2 le 9
le 5 ça rapporte 260 de francs 50
et puis vous ajoutez le 6 et ça rapporte
497 francs 40 à mon avis ce sont les
favoris qui ont gagné même sans me
connaître
voilà tout de suite après ce journal est
bien les prévisions météo josé blanc la
pied appuyé alors donc 19h55 n'oubliez
pas début notre soirée spéciale
élections je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur la prochaine et je
vous dis à samedi prochain bonsoir
pour lui